مجاعه تجتاح البلد نتيجه الحرب الحوثيه
وانعكاسات تونسيه تعصف باطفالي اليمن في
مديريه حيس جنوبي الحديده حيث يصارع عشرات
الاطفال خطر سوء التغذيه الذي تفقم بشكل
كبير في السنوات الاخيره
نقدر نشتري له شيء الطفل ما يروحوا ما
يراوحش عمره ما بين ثلاثه شهور الاربع
شهور اتوفى بسبب ايش سوء التغذيه وهذا اول
مره صراحه يعني يحصل عندنا في البلد
حتى الامهات يعانون من سوء تغذيه الاسره
نفسها تعاني من سوء التغذيه
الاطفال
الحوثي ففي هذا المشفى يخضع العديد من
الاطفال للعلاج بعد تدهور حالتهم الصحيه
فيما ينتظر على ابوابه مالا يقل عن 20
مصابا يوميا املا في العلاج
الحروب وسبب الفقر وسبب انه يعني عوره
الطريق وبسببها اكثر حاجه الالغامه اللي
موجوده
وصول الطفل في حاله مزحه همم
المختلفه في المديريه من الارياف والمدينه
ومن مختلفه الكره المجاوره لها
فالحاله المرضيه التي تصل مختلف انواعها
سواء الاصابات
نتيجه حوادث نتيجه الانفجار الغامدي 200
الى 250 حاليا يوميا مختلف الحالات
المرضيه تشيروا احصائيه الى ان اكثر من 10
ملايين شخص في اليمن يعانون من الجوع وسوء
التغذيه ارقام مخيفه دفعت مركز الملك
سلمان للاغاثه والاعمال الانسانيه الى
توقيع اتفاقيه مشتركه مع برنامج الغذاء
العالمي بقيمه 20 مليون دولار لمواجهه
انعدام الامن الغذائي في اليمن تزداد اذا
نسبه سوء التغذيه في المناطق الساحليه
بشكل كبير خاصه في مديريه حيث هذه
التستقبل المستشفيات العاشرات من الحالات
يوميا رغم صحه الامكانيه فيها هل سعيد
العربيه من مديريه حيث جنبي الحديده